قال ابو راسل الجزيره في كييف ان المضادات
الارضيه للجيش الاوكراني تصدت لصواريخ وسط
العاصمه
من البحر الاسود باتجاه شمالي اوكرانيا
وياتي ذلك تزامنا مع وصول رئيس جنوب
افريقيا سيريل راما فوزا الى العاصمه
الاوكرانيه برفقه الرئيس السنغالي
لتقديم مقترح لوقف اطلاق النار ويضم الوفد
ايضا الرئيس الزامبي كيندي هيشيلي
ورئيس وسوف يتوجه الوفد الافريقي الى
العاصمه الروسيه موسكو في وقت لاحق وزار
الوفد رفقه مسؤولين اوكرانيين منطقه بوتشا
القريبه من العاصمه والتي تتهم كيا بروسيا
بارتكاب مجزره فيها العام الماضي
معنا من كييف المراسل الجزيره عدنان
نابوري عدنان ما الذي حتى الان تبحثوا مع
هذا الوفد الافريقي
نعم الحديث عن لقاءات مع الوفد الافريقي
ما زالت مستمره حتى هذه اللحظه لم يرشح
شيء هذه اللقاءات بطبيعه الحال سيتبعها
مؤتمر صحفي بحسب ما اعلن لكن لا يعلم متى
سيكون ذلك الجديد ان هذا ان هذه الزيارات
وهذه اللقاءات تجري الان على وقع التهديد
والتاهب الجوي هنا في كييف قبل قليل
استقبلت كير او تلقت مجموعه من الصواريخ
الباليستيه انطلقت المضادات الارضيه وتصدت
لهذه الصواريخ بحسب ما اعلنت قوات الجويه
وان تم الاعلان من قبل عمده عن انفجار في
منطقه في منطقه بودلزكي هنا قريبه من هنا
هذا الانفجار موقع الانفجار سنذهب اليه
لاحقا بطبيعه الحال لرسم الذي حدث هناك
بالضبط ان كان الصاروخ استهدف منطقه وقع
في المنطقه اما ان حطامه فقط هو الذي وقع
في المنطقه على اي حال حاله التاهب الجوي
بحسب القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه ما زال ما
زال معلنا كما هنا نتابع هذا التطبيق
يساعدنا ويساعد جميعا من قبل القوات
الدفاع الاوكرانيه على رصد حاله التاهب
الجوي وهي ما زالت معلنه في جميع الاراضي
الاوكرانيه نرصد هذا التاهب بطبيعه الحال
الحديث من قبل القوات الجويه بان هناك ما
زال المزيد من الصواريخ تتجه نحو الشمال
نحو كياب نحو مدن اخرى هذا ما يتم رصده
الناس هنا في حاله تعهد بطبيعه الحال
استعدادا في حال وصلت هذه الصواريخ هنا
للاحتماء في الملاجئ او في الممرات
الارضيه هنا في هذه المنطقه هذه هذه هذا
الاستهداف الذي وقع الان لكي يتعلق عليه
وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني كليب قائلا بان
بناء الثقه الذي يتحدث عنه الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين يبدو انه يبنى باكبر هجوم
صاروخي كما وصفه وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني
تزامنا مع زياره الوفد الافريقي حاليا من
المفترض ان يستمع الرئيس الاوكراني فلادي
لينسكي لهذا الوفد ولمبادرته بعد ان تم
الموافقه اتمت الموافقه على استقبالهم
القضيه
تحاول بناء جسور قويه مع الكتله الافريقيه
على اعتبار انها مؤثره وتتفهم ايضا هذا
الموقف الافريقي المتاثر بالحرب نتيجه
ازمه تصدير الحبوب لكن بنفس الوقت كيف
تتعامل بحذر شديد مع المبادرات المطروحه
وبميزان دقيق كما قلنا من قبل ميزان يقوم
على اساس انسحاب القوات الروسيه من
الاراضي الاوكرانيه هو ارضيه اساسيه لبدء
اي مفاوضات تم التعامل مع مبادرات سابقه
المبادره الصينيه المبادره الاندونيسيه
الاكثر صدا كانت المبادره الصينيه التي لم
تلقى زخما كبيرا النظر للتشكيك الغربي
بالموقف الصيني لكن بنفس الوقت كيف تحاول
الاستماع لهذه المبادرات لكن كما تقول على
ارضيه ارضيه اساسيه قوامها انسحاب القوات
الروسيه من اراضيها
شكرا لك عدنان موريني مراسل الجزيره كنت
معنا من كييف